you guys have fur see the movie Point
Break like when yeah the day my
girlfriend and I only make love with
that movie in the background right yeah
[Laughter]
wild sexual I never stairs it hey guys
I'm Greg Alva
this is Kelly Russo hey hey Kelly
did you like infinity war uh uh I did
but it killed me ah killed me no well I
I loved it and there's a video here by a
channel called looper they have a video
called a game-changing easter egg has
been discovered in infinity war oh let's
see if you notice this or if I noticed
this but I bet you this is one of those
videos that millions of people already
know about butter like told me something
I don't know
cuz that's YouTube comments for you
that's what I like to do I like to smile
I like to make the audience feel welcome
oh that's what I do in real life that's
how I do it on the Internet oh yeah you
can follow Kelly on Instagram and
Twitter if you don't follow her she'll
never come back you got to do that
she's only friends with us for publicity
reason reason promote to further my
career yeah and apparently you need to
have a bigger following on Instagram and
Twitter for dumb [ __ ] like that I'm not
crazy
yeah that's what they look at here just
to talk to you guys yeah because she
cares I do actually
I'm gonna hit play now roll it
eagle-eyed avenges funds have gone and
done it again identifying in the frames
of infinity war well looks to be a clear
blinking you'll miss a reference to
Captain Marvel both the character and
the upcoming movie okay let's go with a
while back by reddit users in the Marvel
Studios subreddit it turns out that one
of the members of finances black order
namely the giant cull obsidian appears
to be stomping around earth to wearing a
sash that seems pretty clearly evocative
of Captain Marvel's red blue and the
gold colors and stripes if you think
really look you call obsidian slash and
thinkin
- the message sent by Nick Fury -
Captain Marvel during the post credits
scene similarity but what does it mean
and there's a slash belong to the
current Captain Marvel or could it hint
at the tragic fate of another fan
favorite character here's what we know
about the upcoming Captain Marvel film
which is set to hit theaters in March
2019 it's set in the 1990s yes how's the
Academy Award winning brie Larson as you
try to be powerful cosmic hero and for
some reason so far we've only seen
images of her wearing a green costume on
set instead of the classic red blue and
gold teased in Avengers infinity war but
we also have some hints from the comics
as well see in the comics Carol Danvers
was introduced to readers as an
earthbound officer of the United States
Air Force who gained her powers to the
accidental fusion of a DNA with a
disguised alien being Elaine's true
identity Captain Marvel of the Kree who
just happened to be thanasis archenemy
after Marvel's tragic death danvers took
on the name Captain Marvel in tribute
now we've already seen the Kree before
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe the
pacers bad guy Ronan the accuser from
guardians of the galaxy was crate more
importantly though in the upcoming
Marvel movie rumor has it that Marvel is
a major character played by Jude Law so
what does it all mean
well it's certainly possible that
colored city in the black order and even
fallows himself have already had a
run-in with Carol Danvers in the past
maybe they even defeated her and cull
obsidian is wearing her costume as a
trophy Oh
but given the events of Captain Marvel
happened two decades before Avengers
infinity war it's theoretically possible
it seems pretty unlikely though
considering how powerful she is in the
comics powerful enough to deck Thanos
himself and Larson has stated that her
film version can literally move planets
so we think that even fans would have
trouble with her
especially since any prior meeting would
have happened before you had the power
of the Infinity Gauntlet a more likely
guess perhaps it's some other Kree waria
who fell in combat with the Black Order
maybe someone like save Jude Law's
original Captain Marvel would certainly
give Carol Danvers a very personal stake
when she joins a fight against Thanos an
Avengers 4 if cull obsidian is wearing
Marvel's tattered costume as some kind
of price it's sort of a shocker that it
took this long for the supposed it
Easter Egg find to gain mainstream
traction because it really is quite
literally sitting there in plain sight
yes the movie that's really awesome I've
never known a sentence or eleventy first
viewing so kudos to all the folks out
there who did capture because this is
super neat we'll find out for sure of
this little infinity war hint ever ends
up paying off next year with the Marvel
doubleheader of Captain Marvel on March
8th followed by the fourth Avengers
movie a short time later on May 3rd huh
we can't wait Easter eggs are always
like right in your face and you just
they're so obviously they look 9 times
out of 10 pages
fly by me I I rarely actually notice oh
that does actually open up the door a
whole lot more the call obsidian but the
colors resembling that of Captain Marvel
for them to have possibly had an
encounter with Captain Marvel in the
past with the curry or whatever that
makes it sound so much more intriguing
because I know Captain Marvel's movies
in the 90s and it's coming out only like
a couple of months or something before
the next Avengers movie comes out which
I thought was kind of strange because of
the fact that there's not gonna be that
big of a gap in between the release
dates of introducing a brand new
character and then you're gonna go into
the next Avengers movie but if Captain
Marvel is a hyperlink to Avengers 4 that
could make for a really interesting tale
it's a movie that takes place in the 90s
and if it kind of ends in a way or
explores the territory where
she's encountered the black order and it
directly goes into Avengers 4 where she
kind of comes out as like the main hero
of Avengers 4 that could be something
very exciting I I love her too and I
would real arson awful she's great she's
great
honestly I don't really know her work
well did you see room that was the only
like huge huge thing I did not because
if I read the Netflix description and it
sounded like the most depressing time in
my life it's so beautiful though she's
incredible
you'll love her and she's just like the
girl next door to I believe all that I
was not gonna watch it as a date night
with my girlfriend okay you should watch
and I don't really know much about
Captain Marvel because I only follow
male superheroes female superheroes who
needs to know about them am i right
Kelly am i right do I just
choke him now after she kills me I'll
edit the video and it'll get so many see
and that shows that people want to see a
female hero and what if a female hero
comes in and saves everyone defeat
Thanos I think we might have a split
audience that I personally think and I'm
not just saying this because you're here
mmm-hmm I personally think that that's a
great idea and it would be so on it
unexpected and it would yeah claiming I
feel like how you handle Captain Marvel
there was age of Ultron which had vision
come in in that movie and then vision
saves the day so I think if they did
that with Avengers 4 where they
introduced Captain Marvel in that movie
and then she saves the day it would be
kind of like oh I would much yeah like
you just introduced her now she's the
big hero come on but if you have a movie
that comes before it
that's an origin tale plus she has some
encounter with the Black Order which is
something I just wasn't anticipating at
all I think that would make it even more
special if she does eventually beat
Thanos or if there's some cuz if they
were showing that comic image where
she's like knocking Tanis out if maybe
Thanos is scared of her
some capacity I'm doing amazing that
would be that would actually be really
cool because a lot of the big talk
because Chris Evans is leaving
Captain America that she could probably
be the new leader of the Avengers which
I think could be cool I said this Easter
Egg got me really excited because I was
just thinking we're gonna watch some
Captain Marvel movie probably doesn't
link to in the next Avengers movie in
any way cuz cuz Black Panther came out
there was no real references to what's
to come for infinity war but infinity
war was the very next movie so I thought
they were kind of doing a similar thing
yeah this opens up my mind to holy crap
we might see like a direct link to
what's gonna happen in Avengers 4 I know
it sounds stupid for like just now
thinking xiety over just how they're
gonna wrap this up how they're gonna
bring back once they killed Black
Panther I was like okay they're going to
bring everyone back like you can't just
establish this amazing character and
then kill them yeah Walker you can no I
think that'd be a good move that was so
fun my Black Panther died no I love
black movies by the way for that anxiety
um you could take lorazepam 0.5
milligrams its medication no I don't I
know the time has passed for me to like
make this random joke about lorazepam
yeah I sponsored so many pharmaceuticals
it's crazy scared about
you can catch at the Comedy Store this
Saturday people 10:00 p.m. go check her
I've hope no yeah I was like this is
random the money I was just mad and now
I'm just excited for the way the fan
boys specifically the fan boys of how
they're gonna be reacting to you know
you know stupidest [ __ ] I read on the
Internet they're just shoving this
feminist stuff in my face it's
overpowering and all these things oh my
god guys you've had like over a decade
of male superheroes let the female
superheroes shine that's just 10 years
of Marvel bunch of other years of you
know chill out I mean it's Catwoman but
that was do you have a sweaty armpit I
think so no I don't hey it's my dress
equality equality yeah a little bit
stain there don't be afraid of shine
don't be afraid to let your pit stains
show Kelly I've never had a pit stain I
don't know what I'm a stains a shirt but
it's like there while it's wet oh wow
that's what yeah you've had that a few
times yeah let's reflect the quality if
a man could talk about this what he pits
woman should be able to as well I don't
know no I think it's the power my dress
smell it nice that's good Kelly's
sexuality you know there are some people
that do when I was at the premiere of
the disaster artist there was a woman
there were very hairy armpits like just
like floor on carpet or might have been
a guy and I just thought it was a woman
I mean to each their own
yeah to each their own them this is how
we do videos here we stay on topic
talk about relevancy yeah no I think
smelling nice as always and appreciated
thing but sweating and Jenner
as healthier it's good for you yeah
thank you I'm glad we got this topic out
of the way I'm glad yeah well Easter
eggs Easter eggs woman's sweat - what do
you go
he's fanboy like we're all humans this
is 2018 yeah all humans let's just enjoy
let's get captain alright guys well did
you see room did it put a smile on your
face
okay yeah I have no idea what actually
goes on I just saw I saw the description
of another plot on Netflix and I was
like this sounds like a terrifying film
right now yeah it's real though that has
happened to a bunch of people oh yeah
I've been in rooms guys she can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
Kelly Russo you can check her out on
Instagram and Twitter Instagram where
she looks like herself she looks great
on there right oh do I look the same a
person as on Instagram that's nice yeah
you do you look do you look the same
yeah you know no catfish in here cuz
that's I mean that's what's cool right
now yeah Instagram hot do I look the
same
yeah she hasn't looked at my Instagram I
have oh my god have you yes gosh
feeling no one looks at my Instagram I
have I want to make sure you're not a
like a serial killer stalker when I come
over to your studio that's why I may
have this whole identity of having a
girlfriend so women feel comfortable
when they come here but really that one
is just Photoshop cos I got her out of a
stock catalogue okay so guys this is my
last transmission donate all my money to
my mother give my brother all my Star
Wars collection goodbye Kelly